- [Instructor] We now have
a lot of experience taking
limits of functions, if
I'm taking limit of f of x.
What we're gonna think about,
what does f of x approach as x
approaches some value a?
And this would be equal to some limit.
Now everything we've done up till now
is where a is a finite value.
But when you look at the graph
of the function f right over here,
you see something interesting happens.
As x gets larger and larger,
it looks like our function f
is getting closer and closer to two.
It looks like we have a horizontal
asymptote at y equals two.
Similarly, as x gets
more and more negative,
it also seems like we have
a horizontal asymptote
at y equals two.
So is there some type of notation
we can use to think about
what is the graph approaching
as x gets much larger
or as x gets smaller and smaller?
And the answer there
is limits at infinity.
So if we want to think
about what is this graph,
what is this function approaching
as x gets larger and larger,
we can think about the limit of f of x
as x approaches positive infinity.
So that's the notation, and I'm not going
to give you the formal
definition of this right now.
There, in future videos, we might do that.
But it's this idea, as x gets
larger and larger and larger,
does it look like that our function
is approaching some finite value,
that we have a horizontal asymptote there?
And in this situation,
it looks like it is.
It looks like it's
approaching the value two.
And for this particular
function, the limit
of f of x as x approaches
negative infinity
also looks like it is approaching two.
This is not always going to be the same.
You could have a situation, maybe we had,
you could have another function.
So let me draw a little horizontal
asymptote right over here.
You could imagine a function
that looks like this.
So I'm going to do it like that,
and maybe it does
something wacky like this.
Then it comes down, and it
does something like this.
Here, our limit as x approaches
infinity is still two,
but our limit as x
approaches negative infinity,
right over here, would be negative two.
And of course, there's
many situations where,
as you approach infinity
or negative infinity,
you aren't actually
approaching some finite value.
You don't have a horizontal asymptote.
But the whole point of this video is just
to make you familiar with this notation.
And limits at infinity
or you could say limits
at negative infinity,
they have a different formal definition
than some of the limits that
we've looked at in the past,
where we are approaching a finite value.
But intuitively, they make sense,
that these are indeed limits.